in the canadian capital
ottawa airport will receive the first
facial recognition terminals
this spring toronto and vancouver
would be in the cards with 130 terminals
only in toronto but who is
behind this
deployment where does the impetus come from that took the
decision via such pressure made
by america a
lot of unanswered questions and
the canada border services agency
even refuses to talk about the
biometric technologies used in
the terminals that will be deployed in the country m
y'a bahrami is a lawyer specializing in
human rights and
national security it is necessary to find a
balance between the
additional security that
these devices could provide the flesh blanchet is an
expert in security we must be wary of
the uses that we could make of
all the information that  would be
harvested by these new systems there a
deployment of these devices in montreal
would be in the cards and it is thought to be
po  could speed up the passage through
customs sometimes overwhelmed
by queues partly linked to a
customs shortage which mayor denis coderre
recently complained about remember then
I called marc garneau the pier
trying to find solutions to the
curses
it  are they going and then things
that are unacceptable
these machines are perhaps therefore quite
simply a technological response to
customs shortages in our airports
the question is is it
also safe to speed up the
process the saas fee
something good it works well
it's the technologies and impeccable
but the holder of
the canada research chair in ethics law and
technologies at the university of ottawa
wenger also wonders what the
purpose is  real of the implementation of this
automatic system
and if it is not a way of
dramatizing the security to
artificially insure the travelers according to
juncker
there is a lot of det  things we do
n't know and as we said to ourselves the
devil is in the details
then he adds there is the idea that if
we equip ourselves with what is perceived as
cutting-edge technology then
travelers will  feel much safer
when in fact humans are
quite capable of looking at a passport
of a person's gaze in front of them is
to tell if it's the same person
customs union
rep yopi press agency  of
the canada border services to explain the
merits of the choice of this system is to
put in place at the very least
guidelines to protect individual freedoms
and privacy we make
it still be the passage of people but
we have the veins  security barriers and
the privacy commissioner of canada,
for his part, is concerned in particular about
the fate of false positives
on these travelers who are constantly
annoyed by terminals
when they arrive in the country yavar hameed
security specialist  national rity
ultimately security in maine in
the area from them it's like a
theater of security so all
kinds of measures are taken
there is no consultation as to
why these measures are being taken but
as we know ourselves with lili
metadata for example only recently
oh it's that even our
security services have been monitoring our own
citizens here in canada including
all kinds of information without
the necessary approval which we already have
to call at lionel  from the precedent on this
a report from radio canada
international